[Applaudissements]
merci cela dans le sac bienvenu ici
c'est le succès six mérités de la
comédie tout ce qui brille qui vous a
rendu célèbre avec un césar du meilleur
espoir à la clé mais avant et après ce
film vous poursuivez une carrière
éclectique au cinéma à la télévision au
théâtre vous a vu chez jacques audiard
cédric kahn pierre jolivet ou brigitte
sy aussi bien que dans des premiers
films comme nous 3 ou rien decarone
césar 2016 dans sa catégorie encore
carnivores jeremy yannick rénier devrons
nous avons parlé tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce qui vous guide aujourd'hui
dans vos choix de films les là alors
effectivement y'a rien de stratégique
c'est des rencontres avec des metteurs
en scène des histoires des personnages
j'ai envie de jouer des choses
différentes oui il ya tout c'est tout ça
qui m'anime
et j'ai très régner en particulier aux
seller j'avais trouvé le scénario gonflé
audacieux c'est c'est je crois que c'est
l'un des rôles je crois que c'est un
rôle de composition les réseaux est noté
à juste titre que brême vous pouvez
possiblement vous attendre dans l'autre
dans l'autre rôle c'est un peu un genre
de contre emploi morath par rapport
notamment à tout ce qui brille ou dans
la relation et géraldine nakache c'était
vous qui brille oui exactement ouais non
vraiment et puis j'ai les frères réunion
réussi à choper un truc de violence en
moi que je n'avais jamais joué de
personnages aussi troublé aussi violent
et j'ai adoré interpréter ce rôle
enfin vous savez qu'ici on est là pour
parler de cinéphilie surtout je me
repose donc vous balader ensemble dans
votre cinémathèque personnel avec le
fameux questionnaire du cirque cette
question comme les sept nains le match
aller là un film et qui vous a donné
envie de faire du cinéma
alors pour être tout à fait honnête je
ne voulais pas être actrice moi donc
j'ai pas eu de film qui m'a ggg des
films qu'on bercé mon enfance mais je
voulais être éducatrice
donc j'ai pas eu de jeu regardaient
vraiment les films en tant que
spectatrice
je ne rêvais pas d'être d'être actrice
donc tokyo n'a pas bougé en a pas
peut-être après une fois vous avez
commencé à tourner non j'ai la strada
c'est l'un des films les plus
je je me souviens est rentré chez moi et
avoir dit à ma mère olala j'ai vu un
film et la dame elle parlait avec ses
yeux et j'ai compris plus tard que
c'était une grande actrice tout l'état
mme hasina parce qu'elle parlait avec
ses yeux voilà intime que vous adorez en
secret alors j'ai je suis très
éclectique comme la musique j'adore
ophélie winter et serge reggiani
je vois là j'assume philippe aussi c'est
vrai vous avez jamais craint dieu m'a
donné la foi tout à l'heure mais là
c'est pas parce que l'on va le faire et
mais c'est vrai que pour les films c'est
un peu pareil j'ai pas j'ai pas honte
d'aimer tel ou tel film par contre pour
vous faire une petite confidence quand
j'ai commencé ce métier je parlais de
melville de sauter de cassavettes au
début je pensais que c'était des noms de
villes surtout mais elles vivent
voilà et ondines et je faisais croire
que j'avais vu l'armée des ombres donc
et puis j'ai rencontré une personne qui
a été et qui est très importante dans ma
vie qui m'a dit tu sais c'est pas grave
ne pas connaître on va là la fnac et on
va acheter plein de dvd et puis on va
découvrir les films ensemble et ça ça a
été extraordinaire parce que parce que
je me suis dit ah ben je n'ai pas pas
honte de dire que sauter me touche plus
que melville et ça fait pas de moi mais
j'ai mis du temps à le film réseau qui
vous a fait le plus de bien leïla bekhti
j'ai vu comme bailleur name
de luca guadagnino exactement je sais
très bien que vous ayez dit son nom
parce que je suis là pour ça on m'avait
beaucoup parlé de ce film et j'ai un peu
de mal j'aime ne pas trop voir les
bandes annonces
on découvre un film et j'ai été assez
fasciné par l'acteur timothy xala mais
ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas eu
un coup de coeur comme ça pour un acteur
j'ai trouvé que c'était
et puis j'étais je me suis sentie
nostalgiques de j'adore les débuts
d'histoires moi et j'étais nostalgiques
de plage était en vacances avec eux
j'étais il m'a fait du bien ce film et
il me reste je ouais j'ai beaucoup aimé
le film
j'ai voté sol mais qui est franco
américains ont du coup on va l'appeler
timothée un peu ce que c'est un peu
comme jean mary pierce gagne roland
garros on l'appelle marie-france perçait
sur canal+ est un acteur leïla ou une
actrice qui vous font aller au cinéma
alors pas forcément pour des raisons
cinématographique
je veux pas faire de name dropping parce
que je déteste remplacer le principe en
même temps maintenant mais c'est vrai
que j'ai par un acte mais c'est mes amis
en fait mes amis qui me donne envie de
bouger car aimer le clou que voilà je
givet et puis en plus je j'adore ces
films à chaque fois donc c'est très bien
mais il ya marina foïs ad l'exarque
poulos marion cotillard voilà ses
défunts voilà effectivement j'y vais
sans me poser de question de me dire
vous avez une bande de potes ya elle
s'écoule un film dans lequel vous
aimeriez vivre les la grise what we
juste pour dire ben moi tes salades nec
c'est vrai que je disais non mais je jeu
j'avais adoré
j'avais tout adoré j'avais dit mais
pourquoi on nous on n'a pas de bal de
fin d'année
mais pourquoi on ne porte pas des délits
la vraie question c'est vous soyez quel
personnage est ce que vous êtes
alors il haut et bas c'est hyper
heureuse que vous vous dites quand
j'étais petit tu aurais t110 parce que
rizzo je la détestais parce que c'était
la méchante et aujourd'hui je voudrais
jouer rizzo oui où nous emmène ce
questionnaire cinéphiles endroit sombre
il est tout à fait pertinent qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez voir plus souvent au
cinéma alors des films sur l'enfance pas
forcément alors pas des films d'enfants
mais des films sur l'enfance
alors il est un peu triste film et c'est
l'un des films qui m'a celle incompris
jeu est alors bizarrement le nouveau sur
un collégien car exactement mais je
trouve que ça manque des films sur
l'enfance et une envie de réalisation là
un jour un film sur l'enfance
ouais un peu ouais ok alors c'est à peu
près le scoop qu'on aura ce soir
ouais un peu ouais enfin un film a
envoyé dans l'espace
vous présentez l'humanité aux aliens
leïla
ah c'est une question importante tant
dans le questionnaire du oui pardon non
je pense que je voudrais pas leur mentir
donc j'en verrai la vie est belle pour
leur montrer que l'homme est capable des
pires atrocités mais capable aussi de de
faire les plus belles choses
et je le revers je leur enverrai aussi
un air de famille pour leur dire qu'on
rigole quand même merci là et là on vous
applaudit
[Applaudissements]